Littlefinger like most characters in The
later seasons was utterly demolished by
David and Dan's incompetent writing so
for this video I want to try my best to
fix his character and to give him a much
better resolution instead of the abysmal
train wreck of an ending he got in
season 7 the first thing we need to do
is assess what made Littlefinger so
great to begin with so we can better
understand why he was lacking in the
later seasons and to me by far
littlefinger's best aspect is that he
plays into one of the show's strengths
which is the rich mystery of conspiracy
littlefinger's deceptive usage of
scheming and backstabbing is so alluring
because he entangles characters in a
thick mud of conflict that drowns them
to me it's more intriguing than
something like dueling because there's
an air of unpredictability as to what
Littlefinger will do we understand his
motives but the actions he takes to
fulfill them is always captivating to
watch unravel this is exemplified the
most in season one where Littlefinger
quite literally kickstarts the entire
conflict of the series Without
Littlefinger there really wouldn't be a
show because think about it Littlefinger
simultaneously manipulates Lysa Aaron to
poison her husband John Aaron which in
turn brings the Starks into the fult and
he hires an assassin to kill bran under
the guise that it was the Lannisters who
did it Littlefinger flat out
orchestrates an entire war in the realm
so that he can profit by helping each
side I feel like by that alone
Littlefinger is the most evil character
in the entire show and most people
normally point to Ramsey or Joffrey the
sheer impact that this character has is
arguably the bigger just right behind
Danny's mad Queen Ark and the night King
you can argue that other villains like
Tywin and Joffrey are more deadly but
they were spurned into doing Hana
actions because of Littlefinger like the
Red Wedding in Taiwan destroying the
riverlands wouldn't be a thing without
Peter what they did in the show comes
nowhere near as close to the massive
amount of damage that Littlefinger has
done to Westeros he is The Mastermind of
most major events and he's the one
that's Paving the way for this
engrossing conflict I'm not going to go
very in depth about what makes the BL
finger so great since this video after
all is about fixing him and not
analyzing his greatness but to put
simply he has a large impact the very
nature of his character is very
mysterious and alluring and the way in
which he overcomes his enemies and
furthers his position is fueled with
high intelligence making every scene
he's in very entertaining and are
constantly excited to see what he's up
to now in the later Seasons all of these
aspects about Littlefinger are severely
downgraded myself and other channels
have been pretty vocal about
littlefinger's handling in the later
Seasons but I feel like I've seen a
common sentiment that Littlefinger was
only ruined in his final season which I
completely disagree with or some people
have even argued that his ending was
actually fine so for this section of the
video we're going to identify where
everything went wrong with Littlefinger
and how he was downgraded so much so I
can then propose fixes to these problems
funnily enough the most pressing issue
isn't actually littlefinger's death but
the exact moment in which he betrays
Sansa by handing her over to the boltons
there's a lot to dive into here and
first let's try to understand
littlefinger's plan for season 5 because
it's very confounding so Littlefinger in
an attempt to Ally himself with the
boltons gives Sansa over to them and he
does this because he's betting that sis
will win and liberate Winterfell his
reasoning for giving Sansa over is that
since she'll be at Winterfell already
sis will then make her Warden of the
north however that immediately doesn't
make sense and is an extremely
convoluted way to be become Warden of
the north instead he could simply Ally
the veil of Stannis and exchange for
helping Sansa becomes Warden of the
north however this isn't actually
littlefinger's plan because he then gets
summoned to talk to Cersei and hatches
an alternate plot with her there he
pitches a plan where he wants Cersei to
send an army of Lannisters to attack
Sis's Army after they win while they're
recovering she says no for obvious
reasons and Littlefinger also proposes
himself to attack with the veil and in
return he wants to become Warden of the
North although Cersei then says that she
wants sansa's head so I guess that
immediately invalidates this entire
pitch because I assume Littlefinger is
lying when he says yes given that he's
in love with Sansa or maybe he's even
lying about that I don't even know
anymore I'd make the case that he does
love Sansa and that kind of aspect about
his character is truly his constant but
after this point Littlefinger literally
disappears from the remainder of season
5 this scene happens during episode 6 by
the way so Littlefinger is Mia for a
long time and I presume that he had no
intentions of sending the veil to
Winterfell since that would be a major
commitment and he'd have to be nearby to
actually attack sis after he won along
with him probably alienating the
entirety of the north by doing that so
yeah there's a lot to unpack here from
how devoid of logic and unnecessarily
complicated this entire plan is
addressing the scene with Cersei first I
assume Littlefinger was shooting for a
hail marry scenario in which sisters
would take out the Victor and establish
him as Warden of the North or something
however that would compromise Sansa so
that wouldn't make any sense this now
makes me think that this entire scene
was just Littlefinger lying to Cersei to
appeaser and if that was the case then
that was unnecessary Cersei is
eventually going to figure out that
Littlefinger is working against her so
he may as well just ignore Cersei and
accept her as an enemy why bother going
all the way down to King's Landing from
Winterfell just to lie to her and gain
practically nothing on top of the fact
that Littlefinger publicly gave Sansa to
the boltons at Winterfell so there 's a
risk in him going to King's Landing
because of the possibility that Cersei
was informed about that like she
coincidentally summons him right after
he shows up in Winterfell with Sansa hm
I wonder what she would want to talk
about so this entire scene with Cersei
feels pointless especially since this
setup leads absolutely nowhere along
with it making littlefinger's plan very
confusing he's doing something
completely unexpected something that has
a sense of motivation behind it but
there's no way to tell what his real
motivation is until you get to the end
of the scene and you realize his real
motivation is what little finger's
motivation always is which is furthering
the the naked self-interest of
Littlefinger now let's go back to
Littlefinger giving Sansa to the boltons
and assume that his initial plan was
betting on sis to win and to establish
Sansa as Warden of the North like before
there's a much better plan available
that achieves the same goal in allying
with Stannis which doesn't alienate
Sansa that just seems like the most
logical approach to the situation
instead Littlefinger throws away that
which he loves the most to the Bolton in
season 6 Littlefinger claims that he
didn't know that Ramsey would be that
unhinged and goes the route of ignorance
I made a
mistake a horrible mistake I
underestimated a stranger like he's not
lying and he genuinely didn't know
anything about Ramsay heard very little
about
you which makes you quite a rare thing
fls go however Littlefinger as a
character Prides himself on being
extremely well informed and would never
act on a plan if there was a variable
that was a major question mark to him as
an example Littlefinger flat out kills
Dante's Hollard because he didn't trust
him to keep his mouth shut since his
future Allegiance was a question mark he
decided that killing him would be a
permanent solution to that problem so
giving Sansa away to an unknown figure
who's the son of a ruthless father who
massacred her entire family is
absolutely wild I feel like it would be
safe to assume that Ramsey would at
least be somewhat like his father and if
not even crazier although it does seem
like Bruce Bolton is mostly
well-mannered but my point still stands
his father frightens me he should he's a
dangerous man you've never asked me
about your mother she was The Miller's
wife apparently they'd married without
my knowledge your consent so I had him
hanged and I took her beneath the tree
where he was swaying she fought me the
whole time she was lucky I didn't hang
her
too in the world of Game of Thrones with
so many crazy Lords it's inherently a
huge gamble to give Sansa away to a
random Lord within a house that is
notorious for flying people I might add
that's by far the most ridiculous thing
that Littlefinger does that immediately
compromises his character littlefinger's
extremely convoluted and nonsensical
plan for this season is like trying to
navigate a complex web of hardened come
it feels like it was made by someone who
doesn't understand the character at all
because it reeks of stupidity it's very
clear that David and Dan were trying to
imitate what Littlefinger would act like
given that they ran out of source
material for him from here we have
season 6 which essentially downgrades
little finger's presence in the show it
mostly feels like David and Dan gave up
doing anything with the character and
pretty much relegated him to trying to
appease sanso for all of season 6
because rightfully so his actions in
season 5 were baffling and not in a way
that you can understand the fault but in
a contrived way in which DAV and Dan
bent the character into a direction that
made him very dumb this leads to season
7 where yet again Littlefinger has a
completely bat sh insane plan of trying
to get Sansa to kill Arya now
Littlefinger is a character that
naturally has to take great risks to
further his position like orchestrating
the entire conflict in season 1 and
conspiring to kill Joffrey however the
difference between those two examples
and a season 7 plot is that they are
much more calculated and safe he only
conspires with people he trusts to stay
quiet and his plans are normally
airtight in season 7 he's basically
trying to convince Sansa that Arya wants
to kill her and become Lady of
Winterfell which this is insane for a
couple reasons firstly and most
importantly Arya notoriously did not
want to be a lady and she wanted to be a
warrior this was very out in the open
and Sansa even hated her for that and
wish Arya would be more like a lady
since arya's more rambunctious
personality would often times compromise
sansa's happiness I started reading the
books recently and they go much more in
depth about this while the show
partially shows this Sansa should
immediately understand arya's core wants
in life and realize that littlefinger's
claim that she wants to be Lady of
Winterfell is I know people can
change in life but Arya is still very
much a warrior and if Sansa was really
suspicious of this she could simply talk
to her sister and try to determine what
her goals are instead of taking
littlefinger's advice someone she knows
she can't trust another issue that
doesn't directly involve Littlefinger as
a character is the contrivance of this
conflict David and Dan essentially bent
arya's character into being
unrealistically cold and crazy towards
her sister when that shouldn't be the
case like Arya gets really mad at Sansa
for writing a letter to Rob to bend the
knee to Joffrey but she was literally
held prisoner and forced to do that even
Rob and his counsil immediately
identified the letter as being
and for some reason Arya goes crazy
about this as if Sansa betrayed her
house and this piece of information will
destroy everything when it shouldn't she
even goes as far to act like she's about
to kill her sister I feel like this is
just an obvious example of David and Dan
exaggerating the amount of anger Ari
would feel here to create a false sense
of conflict not even mentioning the fact
that Sansa could literally go to bran
for Council about this since he told her
he knows everything or bran being the
one to go to his sisters and telling
them about littlefinger's conspiracies
that he literally confirms to
littlefinger's face the fact that
Littlefinger just brushes off the notion
that bran knows about his secret
conversation with Varys is hilarious
bran is clearly indicating to
Littlefinger that he knows what he's
done in the past but Littlefinger for
whatever reason is completely unfaced by
this and Carries On with his ridiculous
plan these are the reasons why
Littlefinger was ruined and people
generally Focus solely on his death
scene as being dumb but in reality it's
everything that leads up to this point
littlefinger's terrible and ruined fate
was fully sealed by this point and his
death essentially evokes no emotion from
how ruined he was from here I'm going to
go into two parts and trying to fix his
character the first one being fixing
everything within seasons 5 through 7
and the the second part will be pitching
an alternative path for the character
that would make more sense and would
better suit him so tackling the season 5
debacle of giving Sansa way to the
boltons I think the most simple change
would be to be more faithful to the
books in the books there's a character
that is friends with Sansa named Jean P
that the Lannister send claiming she's
Arya Stark in the show Littlefinger can
do this and they could simply say he had
her stashed away in his whouse and has
been working there most of the people
currently occupying Winterfell don't
know what Arya looks like so it's
actually a good plan and even if Gina is
questioned about anything she would know
the answers given her close relationship
with Sansa the only people that would
know her true identity would maybe be
some Stark Loyalists and Theon grey Joy
which I think this would make an
interesting dynamic in Theon trying to
keep the identity of Jee paol a secret
essentially adding a more complex layer
to Theon and having to hide information
from Ramsey or maybe he even has to kill
people who suspect her identity as fake
to protect her I admittedly haven't
gotten to this point yet in the books
but it already makes significant iFly
more sense than what David and Dan chose
to do I feel like the main reason why
David and Dan chose to put Sansa Stark
in her place is because they thought it
would make the subplot more dramatic
which I would disagree because we still
have Theon as a point of view character
within Winterfell and like the show this
could be the event that causes Theon to
defect and save Jee from Ramsay's
torture there's a much more complex plot
with man raater going to win ORF to save
Jean in the books but we physically
wouldn't be able to do that since Man is
dead in the show and I don't think it
would be necessary and Theon could come
up with a smart plan to get Gan out
overall this would be more logical From
littlefinger's perspective because he
both gets to keep Sansa to himself and
loyal to him while also making an ally
with the boltons that in his plan of
going to Cersei and getting her to
attack whoever the Victor is wouldn't
compromise Sansa because it would be Gan
instead assuming he still wanted to do
that this seems like such a loow hanging
fruit of a fix that it just makes me
think that David and den didn't really
care about overall logic and only wanted
to raise the drama by turning Jee into
Sansa they severely misunderstood
Littlefinger as a character because even
George R Martin said that Littlefinger
would never betray Sansa and the sad
thing is if it wasn't for bran Sansa
probably would have been manipulated
into killing Arya like a dumbass which
just seems so crazy to me that she still
listens to Littlefinger in season 7 so
that would be an easy fix to the biggest
problem in season 5 and I would also
propose a change in which the conflict
within the Eerie where the Lords don't
trust Littlefinger to not be resolved so
so quickly I think it would be more
interesting to have at least one or two
Lords in the veil to not trust sansa's
testimony or maybe there's a small hole
in sansa's testimony that one of the
Lords notices and investigates further
because currently in the veil there's no
conflict for Littlefinger to overcome
after this trial instead I feel like it
would be a more engaging narrative if
Littlefinger had to covertly deal with
one of these Lords and kill them
essentially utilizing his primary way of
overcoming conflict of scheming and
conspiracy this could Pat out some time
within season 5 five and six because
besides the Winterfell plots
Littlefinger has nothing to do he
literally vanishes from The Narrative
Littlefinger is clearly making enemies
in the veil like him flat out
threatening to kill Lord Roy you could
easily develop a plot thread from there
in which Lord Roy tries to exact revenge
on Peter through his own plan but maybe
Peter makes short work of Lord Royce
because he's inexperienced at playing
dirty and coming up with a plot to get
Littlefinger killed instead Roy kind of
just rolls over and easily submits to
Littlefinger when I feel like this type
of char character would try to Rebel out
of pure spite for littlefinger's
dirtiness and dishonorable nature this
again would give Littlefinger something
to do in season six because now that he
wouldn't have alienated Sansa there will
have to be new material for the
character and I'm not sure if the books
really cover this far for him so this
would essentially be going into unknown
territory for his character that
wouldn't be derived from Source material
because I obviously wouldn't even try to
fix his season 7 plot and would rather
that be removed entirely this is
essentially going into the second part
of of fixing his character and proposing
a different direction and resolution for
Littlefinger I'd argue that Littlefinger
is the most important villain in the
entire show because he's The Mastermind
of everything so having him still be
relevant in a major way I think would be
important for his character and would be
faithful to him instead of utterly
downgrading him to being a Sansa simp
and kissing her toes all the time I
think a longer term goal for
Littlefinger that reshapes the show
would be more interesting while also
being more in character for him for this
pitch since I want little finger to make
a great impact like the earlier Seasons
that means I need to alter the final
seasons of the show so for season 7 I'm
going to solely focus The Narrative on
Danny's war with Cersei and then season
8 primarily dealing with the night king
and the Mad Queen Arc or there could
even be a season 9 where we split the
night king and the Mad Queen Arc but it
doesn't need to be that detailed my
pitch would be after dealing with Lord
Royce and making sure his grasp on the
veil is fully secured Littlefinger
starts conspiring against Cersei in the
hopes that by betraying her Danny will
honor his loyalty by by granting him
more power and wealth some of the
details here could be Littlefinger
killing characters in King's Landing
like maybe kurn to destabilize the
kingdom that could be a factor as to why
the Scorpions were so incompetent in
season 8 kyn could have been possibly
working on designs and Littlefinger
kills them during the process and Cersei
half-hazard implements them even though
they weren't finished that's just an
example of something Littlefinger could
do that simultaneously solves some
problems in season 8 one of the other
ones being kyber's awkward and strangely
funny death scene or you could also save
Kevin Lannister's character from being
killed in the great sep explosion and
have Littlefinger kill him in an attempt
to weaken the laner Army because when
you think of the sept explosion you
probably forgot that Kevin was even
there from how many other characters
deaths overshadowed his so there's a lot
of opportunities for Littlefinger to
cause chaos behind the scenes and in the
process he could be offering up Intel to
Cersei to make her not suspect him as
being a spy after Cersei inevitably
loses to Daenerys this leaves both the
Mad Queen Arc and the night King
conflict both of which I'd still have
Littlefinger playing a major part so
this depends on what should come first
narratively because I feel like the
night King conflict should be the final
Conflict but narratively it feels more
natural for it to happen before the Mad
Queen Arc so I'll do a similar structure
of season 8's plot but obviously
different I won't go into much detail
and we'll only focus on what
Littlefinger does after cersei's defeat
and Littlefinger once again is awarded
for his scheming I would expect Jon Snow
or most likely Varys to convince Danny
to Exile Littlefinger from King's
Landing due to his history of being a
snake he is not to be trusted naturally
this would upset Littlefinger and this
may be a major departure from where the
show went but I think it would be really
interesting if Littlefinger got control
of the Horn of winter given that the
show actually shows it in season 2 when
the Nights Watch was at the Fist of the
first men if you don't know what the
Horn of winter is it's rumored that the
horn if blown will be able to bring down
the wall it technically doesn't come
back up again in the show but maybe
little finger hears rumors about it
being brought to Castle black and he
hatches a plan to steal it the way in
which he hears about it could possibly
be through him East dropping on a
conversation with torman and Jon where
they discuss the horn the wildlings
Apparently know about it through
reputation it would make sense that
finding the horn would be a major goal
for Jon so that no one has the power of
destroying the wall and unleashing the
night King so this would essentially
enact a race between these two parties
and trying to get to the horn first in
stealing the Horn of winter Littlefinger
would replace it with a fake and at the
end of an episode he'll blow the horn a
cool moment could be Jon getting to the
horn and then torman says that it's a
fake cutting to Littlefinger Bringing
Down the Wall thus unleashing chaos into
the realm this would essentially act as
Littlefinger getting revenge on the
Lords and Kings Landing and he will
probably try to profit in some way from
the misery caused by the night King I
think this thematically stays true to
littlefinger's character because he
wants to the realm and benefit
off of its misery which is what he did
in the earlier seasons and it would make
sense for this to remain being the case
along with the fact that Littlefinger
would probably be the only one to
actually want this chaos to unfold I
think in the book yuron is also a
possibility but the tame and destroyed
rendition of him would not make sense
for that to happen in the show so by
making it to where Littlefinger brings
down the wall this would also solve the
major issue in season 7 where tyan comes
up with the atrocious plan of kidnapping
a white that entire plot was extremely
contrived because even if Cersei
believed them she still probably
wouldn't help them which is what
happened and the plot only exists to
deliver a dragon to the night King
however with my pitch I think it would
be much better to make it a character
motivated decision that doesn't
compromise the intellect of a bunch of
characters from this point in the story
I think the most logical path for
Littlefinger would be to retreat to the
veil and ride out the storm to not fully
upset the Lords he might allow some of
his troops to help out in the overall
fight but I find it hard to imagine that
he'll help out completely or maybe he'll
lie about his infantry numbers after the
heroes inevitably defeat the night King
this will now lead us to the Mad Queen
Arc now for this I think a much cooler
development would be for Sansa to still
doubt Dany and overall dislike her but
to build up that distrust over the
seasons instead of it happening
instantly then because of this Sansa
goes to Littlefinger to conspire with
her in taking down Daenerys in a way
Sansa and Littlefinger help orchestrate
the Mad Queen Arc into existence by
doing different things like
assassinating her closest friends maybe
they could even convince Arian to do
this and actually utilize her faceless
assassin skills I know Arya in the show
also kind of has her suspicions towards
Danny so whoever survives on Danny's
side like mande or something can make
for an easy target a great scene could
be Arya wearing grey worm's face and
uses it to kill mande which would be
taking out two characters with one stone
then another example to drive Danny mad
could be planting evidence and making it
seem as if her closest advisers are
actually betraying her like maybe
forging a letter in varys's name that
tells the Lords of Wester that JN is a
Targaryen there's a lot of different
things that you can do that play into
the scheming aspect of the show that can
undermine and drive Danny crazy and from
all of this she begins her descent into
madness and overall paranoia she can't
trust her closest advisers anymore her
friends that celled Mercy have been
assassinated and Jon is slowly but
surely distancing himself from her from
here the same events can play out in the
show where John eventually kills Danny
and this means that little finger makes
it to the end of the show however Sansa
knows the true evil nature of
Littlefinger and I think a suitable
ending would be for her to betray and
kill Littlefinger similar to the ending
of season 7 but done much better in my
opinion maybe a stipulation in
Littlefinger helping Sansa to drive
Danny crazy is that he wants to marry
her which she obviously doesn't want so
she betrays him essentially ending her
Arc of becoming better at playing The
Game of Thrones and using what
Littlefinger taught her against him I
think it would be nice if she comes to
this conclusion by herself and it wasn't
necessarily aided by Bran Bran could
come to Sansa with the information that
he brought down the wall but it makes
for building a stronger and more
independent character if she wasn't
given this information on a golden plate
and I know bran is kind of a wildcard
character that with his very existence
can curb stomped Littlefinger out of the
show but I really like the evil bran
theory in which he knew what was going
to happen but he let it happen anyways
bran wanted to become the king and
create a prosperous realm so he allowed
all of these terrible things to happen
so he could get there which would be my
reason for bran not ratting out
Littlefinger right away he knew
Littlefinger would serve his common
interest so he allowed him to live
unlike the show where bran sepson
because Littlefinger was about to
manipulate Sansa into killing Arya
little finger's death won't be a major
blunder made on his part that was just
insanely dumb but a betrayal from
someone he never expected Sansa uses the
lust that Littlefinger has towards her
against him so yeah this is a massive
rework for littlefinger's character that
I think would be a much more
satisfactory than what we got I know
requires altering the story a bit and
how it's formatted but realistically if
David and Dan still cared about Game of
Thrones then they wouldn't have rushed
it with two shortened Seasons like it's
wild to me that they did cersei's
downfall the long night and the Mad
Queen Arc in six episodes that's purely
insane and with this chain to
Littlefinger it made sense to fix other
things that David and Dan also broke
because it would be physically
impossible to give Littlefinger great
Arc in the current state of the show
sorry this video ballooned in size and
hopefully my pitch for the character was
satisfactory I'd love to go more in
depth about it but this video would
become 40 minutes long probably thank
you for watching in my letter box
patreon and Discord link are in the
description and if you made it to this
point then you may as well
subscribe